welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Deadpool's introduction the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is eminent
according to Ryan Reynolds himself
taking some kind of major meeting at
Marvel Studios even if it wasn't
actually for the role of Anthony Stark
though
Deadpool rising from that grave and
spider-man's acid trip would be very
unbound for him jokes aside Reynolds was
mating with Marvel Studios for some
reason and that reason was almost
certainly Deadpool's first appearance in
the MCU and thanks to some redbull
Ettore teases from the creators behind
the Deadpool movies we are finally
getting a clearer picture of what the
MCU Deadpool will look like and how much
of its disgusting body and nick fury
will be forced to look at this time you
trust someone he may want to lose his
other eye join me as I explain the
latest updates about Deadpool in the MCU
in this episode of inside Marvel's okay
since Disney's buyout of Fox's Marvel
properties was finalized earlier this
year Deadpool was the most popular and
promising title from that group after
x-men dark phoenix disney head bob iger
confirmed that while the x-men and the
Fantastic Four would be rebooted under
Kevin Feige stewardship Deadpool would
be the one hero kept as is ain't broke
say you ain't gonna fix them even though
fixing his broken self is pretty much
his MO anyway the biggest concern with
this transition of course is the fact
that Ryan Reynolds Deadpool has always
been very very very r-rated and the
Marvel Cinematic Universe like most
verses in the house of mouse is very
very very family-friendly PG the
exception being the Pixar Cars universe
in which Lightning McQueen and mater
roll around with rotting human corpses
inside them because what happened to the
humans apologies it's a fixation that
I'm desperately trying to get over
anyway when it comes to Deadpool
Deadpool to director David Leitch has
suggested an MCU Deadpool movie doesn't
necessarily have to be r-rated but more
recently Deadpool co-writer Paul Wernick
confirmed that Marvel promised to
continue to let them play in the r-rated
Deadpool universe so what does that mean
well it means that the third Deadpool
film will likely be r-rated as the first
two Deadpool movies work and they will
now occupy a corner of the MCU where
things can be more violent or profane
and more obscene but because this corner
is still links to the MCU it can contain
Easter eggs direct references and cameos
by actual elements owned by Marbles
now this is Deadpool so jokes and meta
commentary about this delicate
transition will probably be a big part
of Deadpool 3 but instead of cameos like
the cast of x-men apocalypse in a
background room at the x-mansion Wade
Wilson canal crash-land in the sanctum
sanctorum and complaining that Bruce
Banner left the people in that crater
whereas before we saw Colossus duking it
out with juggernaut now Colossus can
swap lifting tips with the Hulk Thor
Korg and cable can now have a very
interesting conversation with Thanos
expect this Deadpool corner of the MCU
to be a more integrated MCU corner than
the blocks of Manhattan where daredevil
punisher Luke Cage Jessica Jones and
iron fist
took place in in their Netflix series
separate but with more than just the
occasional reference to the Battle of
New York or some Midtown building
conveniently framed in front of the
Avengers Tower so that we never see it
in fact there's a good chance a Deadpool
could embrace this separate corner
concept with the Marvel Netflix
properties like he could be the one who
reintroduces Matt Murdock Frank Castle
and the rest to the MCU joking about how
different they look and how weird it is
if they never cross paths with superhero
that they share a half mile radius of
real estate with what exactly will this
Deadpool in an r-rated MCU corner look
like before it continued thanks to fan
power for sponsoring today's episode fan
power is a new app that gives fans of
any pop culture a way to stay connected
with their favorite fandoms whether
you're in a Marvel Comics episodes of
Rick and Morty any kind of game you can
find over 500 like-minded communities to
geek out over what you love then your
feet will be populated with content to
help you discover new fans and
collectors fan power also curates the
best pop culture news from across the
Internet to keep you up to date on all
the stuff that you're in to end up where
collectors out there fan power was built
to help you digitize organize and show
off your collectibles so that you can
take your trophy room with you wherever
you go so now I have a mobile way to
show off my fandom instead of a my wall
of lightsabers that I have to try to
invite people inside my house to see and
no one ever comes to visit also for a
limited time dan power is giving two
lucky winners a brand new Nintendo
switch light boom baby all you got to do
to enter is download the app share a
geeky moment or collectible in you're in
it to win it
winners will be announced exclusively on
fan power so head over and download fan
power now okay let's see if we can
figure out how Deadpool makes his
r-rated entrance into the MC
imagine a post-credits scene following
dr. strange and the multiverse of
madness coming May 2021 with a title
like multiverse of madness the film will
likely open all kinds of
interdimensional doors throughout the
MCU
with one of those doors perhaps leading
to other r-rated corners where folks
like Wade Wilson have time-travel
capabilities and Josh Brolin is not
purple multiverse of Madison's
post-credits scene could feature
Deadpool being spit out from a quantum
realm time vortex at least Scott Lang
was that this time Deadpool's being spit
out into the sanctum sanctorum brushing
Sparks off his suit smacking his
time-travel wristwatch that he got from
cable and Deadpool to Steven trains
could look down on him from the upper
level of the sanctum and weighed like
Peter Parker in his far from home post
credits scene except in this pg-13
Quarter the MCU the swear is censored
maybe my strange putting on an anti
profanity curse on its mouth or strange
like melts is now like Neos was this
self-aware censorship could be the
running joke of a third Deadpool film
set in the MCU sometime after this
Deadpool could stumble in and out of
scenarios with the other Marvel heroes
who are hanging around dr. strange Hulk
for T'Challa
and find that every time he tries to be
true to himself he gets shut down in
some hilarious way like when Deadpool
tries to make a sexual gestures Hulk
could just cover it up with his huge
hand and block it from a group of
gawking school kids or when Deadpool
tries to swear Sam Wolfson could frisbee
the cap seal of his head and shout
language essentially we could be looking
at a parody film of spider-man
homecoming but with Peter Parker swapped
out for the MCS new homecoming hero Wade
Wilson struggling to fit in with an
Avengers dominated world that forcing
him to prove himself before he can be
one of the guys a hamstrung Deadpool in
the MCU would be just like Peter Parker
stuck in the training wheels protocol
Deadpool training wheels protocol would
be for him to prove himself as a team
player with strangers who do not play as
dirty as he does and instead of Deadpool
3 it could simply be titled according to
the MCU spider-man films with their home
theme like Deadpool home wrecker
throughout it all deadpool could do
exactly what he does best
mock the hell out of every superhero he
knows about and with his ability to see
through the fourth wall could also make
fun of all the studio drama behind them
including like the disney's sony dispute
over the spider-man title and disney's
gradual buy out of everything with a
Hulse except this time deadpool will be
doing it all to their face it's really a
better way to phrase that
how do you think Deadpool will join the
MCU comment down below with your
thoughts and if you can manage it we
would love your support to help us build
a new permanent home of new rockstars
Digital Studios you can do by becoming a
patron patrons can get early access to
certain videos and an exclusive monthly
breakdown just for the patrons which for
this month to celebrate Halloween will
be Stanley Kubrick's The Shining check
out the link below for details and is
special thanks to one of our beloved
patreon BM havoc Thank You bud follow me
on instagram and twitter at EA vas thank
you for joining me and if de people
really wanted to land with a splash in
the MCU he really should titles next
movie something like Deadpool home sweet
home
[Music]